Charles: J.D., I don't use the word hillbilly,
you know?
I always talk about country people and that
sort of thing and I've always felt kind of
shy about using it, and then you used it proudly.
Tell me, what is a hillbilly?
Vance: Yeah, well, so as my grandma said,
"A hillbilly is something that we can use
in the family, but if somebody else calls
you a hillbilly then you have to punch them
in the nose."
And the idea is that it's an insider's term
of endearment and the way that we used it
in our family is one, that you had some connection
to the land of Appalachia or Appalachia, depending
on where you're from, how you say it, that
you really love that land and you love the
people who live there, and I do think that
there's a sort of country element to it.
It's not just about Appalachia itself.
It's sort of about loving the rural lifestyle
and having some connection to it, either familial
or otherwise.
Charles: You've had the book out for a while.
You've had all sorts of people do exactly
what I did, tell you about how, oh yeah, they
came from a similar kind of family and the
rest of it.
To what extent do you still see the hillbilly
culture in which you grew up to be distinct
from other white working class environments
that people have talked to you about?
Vance: Yeah, so that's a very interesting
question.
I think the answer is that it's still somewhat
distinct, and a lot of what we think of as
white working class culture, I still think
that what we're really talking about sometimes
is sort of Scots-Irish or Appalachian rooted
culture.
Obviously there's been so much assimilation
that it is sometimes hard to figure out where
one stops and the other begins.
But there is this interesting argument that
we ought to just call it the United States
of Appalachia because a lot of what we think
of as sort of classically American values
are really rooted in Appalachia in different
ways.
There's a really good book to that effect.
But I think that it's important to sort of
recognize, and one thing I've tired to do
is recognize that a lot of these issues agree
in the broader white working class, but I
do still think that there is a lot of connection
to Appalachia.
Charles: Well, you know, in the census responses
the group of people that responds to the question
of "What is your ethnicity, background, your
ethnic background?" the ones who say, "I'm
American" are the Scots-Irish.
Vance: That's exactly right, yeah.
Charles: Which in my case, I've always bragged
about my Scots-Irish background and I have
said, "Well, we were violent and we were drunk,
but we made great pioneers."
I didn't know the half of it until I read
your book, in terms of all kinds of stuff
that goes on in the culture you describe.
Question, to what extent... you're a child
of the 90s, right?
Vance: That's right.
Charles: You basically were growing up then.
As you listen to your parents and your grandparents,
to what extent has the hillbilly culture evolved
since 1960?
Vance: Yeah, well, I think it's definitely
evolved almost because it's been forced to
evolve, right?
So one of the things my grandparents, I think,
realized after they moved to southern Ohio
was that a lot of the values that they brought
with them didn't necessarily translate into
sort of middle class American life.
Charles: No kidding.
Vance: I think because of that, especially
among sort of upwardly mobile folks who have
some connection to Scots-Irish or Appalachia,
there is definitely an impulse to sort of
discard your hilllbillyness.
There's recognition that it's maybe something
to be ashamed of or maybe just something that
you don't want to highlight.
I think it's been really interesting, actually,
since the publication of the book, to watch
my cousins who both grew up in very sort of
middle class families, they're both in college,
one is 21, one is 19, and the way that the
book has sort of brought them back in contact
with their roots, because I mean they knew
my grandma very well and they didn't realize
how much she was a sort of cultural figure
and how much they really are part of that
culture even though they don't necessarily
see it as something that's broader than themselves.
Charles: Are these relatives of yours who
are the children of the one...is it Milwaukee
he went to?
Vance: No.
So Uncle Jimmy is in Texas.
He went from Middletown to Texas to California
and back to Texas.
These are children of Aunt Wee, who is sort
of a very important character in the book.
Charles: And to what extent were they aware
of the heritage that they had?
You said they didn't know your grandmother
was the way she was?
Vance: Well, no.
They certainly knew the way that she was,
and I don't know that they quite placed it
in a broader regional and cultural context.
And so one of the really interesting things
that my cousin did, she wrote this really
beautiful piece about my grandma and about
sort of recognizing where she came from in
the wake of the book coming out.
But she even said she sort of tried to hide
her hillbillyness.
She didn't tell other people about these outrageous
family stories, and I didn't either until
I got older.
I started to appreciate that they were maybe
something unique and interesting and not something
to be just ashamed of.
But it was only after I graduated from high
school, you know, as I said in the book, a
lot of my very good friends heard about these
stories for the first time while reading them
in the book.
It's not something I really bragged about
until I got older.